[संगीत]
हेलो
और अभी अपन लोग चालू करेंगे अपना पाइथन का
सेशन जिसके लास्ट दे वन है
और मैं हूं
सिक्योरिटी
कैसे पाइथन राहत है क्या पाइथन क्या चीज
है पाइथन ये बेसिकली मैं बता डन ये सांप
नहीं है ये अपना प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज है
पाइथन
देखते हैं अभी अपन आगे इसको कैसे रखना का
है
सबसे पहले अपने समझते हैं की प्रोग्राम
क्या होता है और इस के साथ के अंदर पैटर्न
कल सबसे पहले देखते हैं सब लोग चाट पर या
ना सो ओपन देखते हैं किन-किन को पहले
प्रोग्रामिंग आई है या किन लोगों ने पहले
प्रोग्रामिंग कर राखी है तो वो लोग प्लीज
चाट में लिख डॉग उनको कौन-कौन सी लैंग्वेज
आई है या कौन-कौन सी लैंग्वेज इस मतलब वो
पाइथन पर अगर कम कर रखें हो तो थैंक यू हो
जाएगा ये समझना में की किसको कितना नॉलेज
है
एचपी प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज नहीं है
एचटीएमएल बगल में लैंग्वेज नहीं है पीएसपी
है सॉरी एचटीएमएल प्रोग्राम
के अंदर तुमको एक लाइन के अंदर हो जाएगा
इस चीज की गारंटी अभी मैं तुमको लाइव करके
दिखाने वाला हूं की वो कैसा राहत है तो
सबसे पहले यह समस्या की प्रोग्रामिंग होता
क्या है
तो प्रोग्रामिंग प्रोग्रामिंग कुछ नहीं है
बस जिंदगी को आसन करने के तरीके कंप्यूटर
की लाइफ में जो जिंदगी अपनी चल रही है उसे
जिंदगी को ऑटोमेटिक करना आसन करना मतलब
खुद के अलग रीजंस वियाग्रा लिखना है वो सब
कुछ अपना आता है प्रोग्रामिंग के अंदर अब
इसके बहुत सारे लैंग्वेज वगैरा भी है सी
सी प्लस प्लस
बहुत साड़ी लैंग्वेज और भी है किसी लोगों
ने भाई लैंग्वेज सुना होगा अभी बहुत
बढ़िया चल रही है भाई अगर तुम लोगों ने
देख लेना वो भी बहुत अच्छी है
है और साथ देखते हैं की मतलब पाइथन ही
क्यों मतलब पाइथन क्यों पान को पढ़ना
चाहिए सबसे पहले जैसे मैंने बताया है की
सी और सी प्लस प्लस ज्योग्राफी है आसन है
ठीक है तो एकदम बहुत सिंपल है इसका सब कुछ
पासवर्ड आएगा कोड एक लाइन के अंदर और मतलब
बहुत सिंपल से कमांड प्रिंट हो गया और पट
मतलब बहुत इजी इजी से इसके अंदर केवल रहते
हैं साथ ही कम्युनिटी इतनी बढ़िया है ना
की मतलब तुमको कोई भी दिक्कत आई है ना लिख
के ले लो वो एक चीज किस तरह किसी को पहले
राखी होगी रखा होगा गूगल पे अगर गूगल में
बेस्ट मतलब मैं क्या का रहा हूं अभी मैं
कुछ जगह भी पढ़ा रहा हूं तो मैं पाइथन अगर
मुझे भी कुछ अगर कोड चाहिए राहत तो गूगल
ही करता हूं कोर्ट मतलब ऐसा नहीं है की
मतलब मेरे को सारे याद रहते हैं सारे
सिंटेक्स वगैरा सब कुछ दिखा देते हैं गूगल
करता हूं गूगल के अंदर तुमको वेस्ट साइड
बताऊं तो w3schools और ग्रीक्स करके एक और
वेबसाइट है ये दो तो बेस्ट है ठीक है तो
और साथ में अपना पैटर्न ओपन सोर्स है
ठीक है मतलब ये राहत है की अपन इसको फूल
ही उसे कर सकते हैं कुछ भी चीज हो तो अपन
इसको एडिट कर सकते हैं कोई अपन को खाने
वाला नहीं है कोई ठोकने वाला नहीं है कुछ
भी नहीं डिमांड बहुत है फैसल स्किल की अगर
बात करते हैं तो
पीठ नहीं लगती है मैनली
क्योंकि पाइथन का सीन है वह हर किसी का
कंपैटिबल राहत है पता नहीं पाइथन मतलब
पाइथन से पाइथन कोर्ट हमारा हर ओपनिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर भी चलेगा लिरिक्स
इसी के अंदर अभी भी चलेगा ठीक है अब पाइथन
अपना बहुत जगह भी इस्तेमाल होता है जैसे
वेब डेवलपमेंट वगैरा सब जगह स्टाइल होता
है अपना आगे देखेंगे इस चीज के बड़े में
सो सबसे पहले पाइथन क्या होती है पाइथन एक
बंधन है मतलब जोड़ियां वंशम करके मुझे भी
नाम प्रोनाउंस करने में नहीं हो रहा है
नित थ्योरी वाला चीज मेरे भी सब ऊपर से
जाता है बट एक बता रहा हूं मैं 1991 में
रिलीज हुआ था तो ये इस्तेमाल होता है अपने
वेब डेवलपमेंट के अंदर सर्वर साइड के अंदर
जैसे इसके अंदर फ्लैस्क आता है और साथ में
जैंगो भी राहत है तो ये ये में है फ्रेम
वर्क जिसमें जिसके चक्कर में अपन बैक और
का कम कर सकते हैं तो अगर तुम लोग चाहे तो
हमें भी पढ़ाई अच्छी लगती है तो अपने इनके
बड़े में भी आगे बात कर सकेंगे तो
सॉफ्टवेयर डेवलपमेंट
इजीली हो जाता है तो यह साड़ी चीज एकदम
बढ़िया है
जिनका सवाल है
वीडियो में बताया था 7 दिन का कोर्स चाहिए
तो शादी रखना चलेगा
अब देखो इतना अपन के बड़े में देखेंगे
पाइथन ऐसा है वैसा है इतनी खूबियां है तो
हर सिक्के के दो पहलू होते हैं ठीक है तो
बहुत मतलब खूबियां भी है तो खामियां भी
बहुत साड़ी है
की सबसे पहले समझते की कंपाइलर क्या होते
हैं ठीक है अब बाकी सी और सी प्लस प्लस
क्या करता है ना की एक लाइन पड़ेगा
तो रिफ्लेक्टर हो जाते हैं
ठीक है तो और अपना क्या राहत है ना की
पाइथन इंटरप्रेटर वेस्ट लैंग्वेज है
बाकी सब कुछ पैटर्न में बढ़िया है बस वही
की वो इंटरप्रेटर भेजता है ठीक है अब अब
अपना ये साथ दिन का जो कोर्स है इस कोर्स
के अंदर अपना क्या-क्या रहेगा मोडल वगैरा
वो अपन देखते हैं लेवल के अंदर अपने
इंट्रोडक्शन वगैरा आज कर देंगे
इंट्रोडक्शन और सॉल्यूशन वगैरा आज देखेंगे
कल अपन लिस्ट वगैरा क्या होते हैं उन सबके
बड़े में देखेंगे उसके अगले दिन थर्सडे
अपन देखेंगे अपना डिक्शनरी क्या होती है
ऑपरेशंस वगैरा क्या होते हैं
अपन देखेंगे
की फाइल हैंडलिंग कैसे करनी होती है
नहीं तो मेरे पास भी है एक दो प्रोजेक्ट
के लिए चालू करते हैं अपना बेसिक
इंस्टॉलेशन और कोडिंग वगैरा
सब लोग अपने क्रोम के अंदर डाला
हां और पाइथन जो है वह अभी अपन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के हिसाब से भी करेंगे की कैसे
बना सकते हैं एक बहुत में टूल तुमको देखा
तो आप प्लस
गूगल पे सर्विस टाइप करना ये टीम
मैट्रिक्स का लिखा ये चेंज हो गया रहेगा
यहां पर आने वाला रहेगा
सो ये भी टूल पूरा साइबर सिक्योरिटी बेस्ट
है जो
पाइथन वे माला है फूली पाइथन भेज रही है
तो ऐसे टूल्स अगर ये अपन आगे आगे बनाएंगे
और साथ के अंदर अभी इतना तो अपन कर पाएंगे
की
अपने को कोई भी पूरा तुमको कुछ भी नहीं
बड़ा सकता ठीक है थोड़ा पटाया जाता है
बाकी या खुद ही देखना पड़ता है ठीक है सो
यही रहेगा इसके अंदर
बनाने को सीखेंगे अब सबसे पहले पाइथन की
सॉल्यूशन वगैरा के देखते हैं तो यहां पे
पाइथन डाउनलोड करके लिख देना
जैसे लिखोगे तो यहां पर पैटर्न जो लोग
विंडोज वाले विंडोज के हिसाब से अपना अपना
वैसे देख लेना तो अपन डाउनलोड करना चाहते
हैं
वह अपने हिसाब से डाउनलोड कर लेना
पैटर्न इंस्टॉल
कहानी पर भी जाके करोगे तो इंस्टॉल हो
जाएगा नहीं तो फिर पाइथन के पाठ पर जाके
तुमको इंस्टॉल जो भी राहत है पाइथन का वो
करना पड़ेगा
[संगीत]
की पाइथन के सॉल्यूशन वाला पार्ट यहां पर
खत्म हो जाएगा अपने सॉल्यूशन हो जाएगा तो
उसके बाद में यहां पे
आइडिया लिखना
अभी जो भी अपने सामने खुला यह शैलीपैथ यह
पाइथन का सेल तुम्हारे हर ओपनिंग सिस्टम
करना जाकर खुला जाएगा कहानी कहानी पर भी
जाके सीएमडी में जाके पीथल लिख डॉग तो भी
ये ₹6000 यहां पे खुला जाएगा ऐसे और शैली
करना जो भी तुम लिखोगे तो उससे कटिंग
मैथमेटिक्स कैलकुलेशन लोगों ने छोटा मोटा
जो एक-एक लाइन का जो कोड होता है वो ओपन
यहां पे एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं जैसे
ए = 10 लिख दिया तो यहां पे ए करूंगा तो
देख ले यहां पर ए जाएगा
ठीक है सो ये छोटा वाला सेल है यहां पे वन
प्लस तू करूंगा तो यहां पे थ्री ए जाएगा
लिखा हुआ तो ये छोटा मोटा चीज है इसको अगर
एग्जिट करना हो तो
एग्जिट कर सकते हैं
ठीक है
जो लोग को क्वेश्चन
लिखा हुआ है की सर्विस कैसे कम कर रहा है
क्या ये सब कुछ
सो ऐसे ही रहेगा
[संगीत]
सबसे पहले बेसिक सा पान चालू करेंगे यहां
पर लिखेंगे प्रिंट
हेलो
वर्ल्ड
खड़े कर दो
यहां पर
पड़ता है
भाई डिपेंड करता है
या छोटा भी टॉपिक जैसा इंट्रोडक्शन
[संगीत]
ठीक है प्रिंट टाइप
क्लास इसका मतलब है और जो मैंने कोड लिखा
है इस कोड का क्या मतलब है
टाइप किया है सॉरी
अब यह जो टाइप आया है
सिंपल प्रिंट टाइप 10
इससे अपना क्या निकाला
है
ठीक है
सो ए = 10
तो पहले 10 आया फिर 12 आया
उसके बाद अपने ए का वैल्यू चेंज करके
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज से अगर कंपेयर करें
तो यहां पर लिखो
10 करके लिखो फिर जाके बाद में प्रिंट के
लिए करो सिस्टर को डॉट प्रिंट टैलेंट
ज्यादा वालों के लिए शास इन अपना बालों के
लिए
तो यह चीज अगर तुम नोटिस कर का रहे हो तो
ये चीज कितना इजी सा हो रहा है मतलब एक दो
लाइन के अंदर भी अपन सभी चीज अपन कर का
रहे हैं
बहुत खूब
सिंटेक्स कहां ग रहा है
साइड में रखते हैं डिक्शनरी का अपन एक अलग
से ही देखेंगे पूरा तब पूरा ओपन करेंगे
डिक्शनरी का
लाइन नंबर ओके
ठीक है यह खुशी ही ले रहा है तो यह बहुत
अच्छी चीज लगती है पाइथन के अंदर की अभी
कुछ डिफाइन नहीं करो कुछ मतलब फॉक्स की
झंझट बाजी नहीं है इसके अंदर बट अगर एक
तुमको फनी फैक्ट बताऊंगा इसके बड़े में की
ये इतना इजी होने के बाद में भी इसकी जो
जीते भी इंटर्स वगैरा जो भी कंपैरिजन
वगैरा रहते हैं अपने पाइथन के वो साले वो
सारे के सारे सी के अंदर लिखे जाते हैं
ठीक है और सी इतनी हार्ड है बाकी पैशन
इतना इजी और ये लिखा हुआ सी के अंदर है तो
ये बहुत एक और अजीब सी बात मुझे ऐसी लगती
है बट जो भी है यही अपने सामने
तो अब अपन देखते हैं की अगर मां लो की अगर
ये ए है अब ये अपना लिस्ट है अब मुझे अगर
इसको स्टेपल है ये अपना भी एक टप्पल है
अगर अपन इस सबल को मगर मुझे लिस्ट में
कन्वर्ट करना है तो मैं इसको लिस्ट कैसे
कन्वर्ट करूंगा बहुत इजी यहां पर आगे लिख
दूंगा लिस्ट
हो गया
मैं कल बताने वाला था बट अगर अपन को लिस्ट
को डिफाइन अलग-अलग करना हो यह कौन क्या है
तो यह ब्रैकेट से होता है
अगर से यहां पर
लिस्ट है अगर ऐसे यह
तो यह अपना टप्पल है
मतलब टाइप चेंज करने का भी अपना लक कैसा
है
ये देखो ये मैंने प्रिंट कराया था तो यहां
पर इसके ब्रैकेट चेंज हो गया लिस्ट हो गया
सबको मेरी आवाज वगैरा ए रही है ना
एकदम बाद में देखेंगे
और भी बहुत डर टाइप कर रहे होते हैं वह
चीज
वगैरा भी होते हैं वो चीज अपन टाइम आने पे
सब होगा
माना लेकिन अभी यहां पे बहुत से और भी लोग
हैं जिन लोग को नहीं आता है
तो उनको भी बताने का है और अंदर चला जाता
है और अपना बुलियन वगैरा भी आएंगे अभी तो
बुलियन वगैरा का भी अपन देखेंगे आगे जाके
की कैसा राहत है उसका
पेन लिखा था
ठीक है
इंटीरियर
का इनपुट भी लेना होता है
हुआ क्या ना इसके अंदर यह इसने इनपुट
मांगा और जो अपन को वहां पर प्रॉब्लम
दिखाना है की यहां पर क्या लिखा हुआ आना
चाहिए ओपन
प्लस वगैरा कुछ लिखने हैं मतलब वो
डिजाइनिंग अपनी यहां पे कुछ भी लिख सकते
हो उससे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता अपन देखो ये
ये वाले जो अपना डबल कोड्स है इसके अंदर
जो कुछ भी लिखेंगे ना वो आज आईटी इस वैसा
का वैसा आएगा जरूरी नहीं है की अपन को वही
चीज लखनी हो जो मैंने लिखी है या कुछ भी
लिख सकते हैं वह फंक्शन कुछ भी लिखोगे तो
चलेगा यहां मैं हार्दिक लिख दूंगा कुछ भी
लिखूंगा ना यहां सब कुछ चलेगा
ठीक है तो और यहां पर जो भी जैसे जो चीज
यहां पर ये सामने ए जाएगा यहां पर उसके
बाद अपन यहां पर जो इसको इनपुट डालेंगे ये
इनको डालने के बाद में सीधा अपने जाके शोर
हो जाएगा जैसे शोर होगा तो उसके बाद में
जाके अपन करवा सकते हैं
की मैंने यहां पर ये डाला है
ठीक है
हां भाई डिलीट है
और कोई
एंड्राइड टाइप
करेंगे
अभी बहुत स्लो इंतजार
करता हूं लेकिन इसका लॉजिक कुछ और है
इसके नसीब ऐसा है ना तो सबसे पहले वो
वैरायटी फूल स्ट्रिंग ही लेट है अब मुझे
इसको बताना है की भाई इनपुट तेरा इंतजार
में आएगा
तो मैं उसके लिए यहां पर क्या लिखूंगा ना
इसके आगे अपने इसका टाइप फास्ट कर दिया
ठीक है इंतजार है तू
टाइप दिखा दिया
मैंने पढ़ा था की अगर मां लो की मैंने
यहां पर तो स्ट्रिंग वैल्यू डाला
तो वह कन्वर्ट हो गया अच्छी बात है अगर
मैं यहां पे ऐसा हार्दिक वादी को लिखो
इंतजार में कन्वर्ट कैसे होगा तो
इस क्वेश्चन का समाधान अपने अपने
सीखने वाले हैं ठीक है यह एरर अपने कोड
में नहीं है यह एरर अपने यूजर है
की यहां पर अपन को इंटीरियर डालने का है
तो तू कहे को मैं सरिता डालना है कुछ ऐसे
वैसे दाल रहा है
ये आगे चलकर देखने वाले हैं
ठीक है
अपने जो यूजर है वो यूजर खराब था ठीक है
ना तो ऐसे बहुत सी चीज होती है जो अपन को
हर हर पॉसिबल पॉसिबिलिटी अपन को देखने में
पड़ती है की क्या-क्या उसे इनपुट कर सकता
है और क्या-क्या चीज इसके अंदर हो शक्ति
है
रेडी रहना पड़ता है
ठीक है तो वैसे ही राहत है
डालते हैं वो अपन आगे देखेंगे ठीक है
अब हम इसके बड़े में और थोड़ा देखते हैं
अब मैं चाहता हूं की वह अपने
जो मेरा आएगा
ठीक है
बहुत बढ़िया भाई मोहम्मद
चलो ठीक है थैंक यू कभी-कभी
क्या
शंकर
फिर भी मेरी गलती
है
हां तो ओपन
ने कोई कोड लिखा यह भी कंपनी छोड़ देते
हैं अगला वाला प्रोगामर देखिएगा तो भाई
अगले वाले प्रोग्राम
ने जो कोड लिखा है वह कोड को समझे कैसे या
फिर अपन ने भी कोडिंग लिखी है तो बहुत से
ऐसे पड़ा है मैं अगर आपको मेरा एक
टेस्टिंग का फोल्डर खोल के दिखाऊंगा तो
उसमें बहुत सारे फाइल्स वगैरा बनी है
पाइथन की मैं कमेंट लिखना भूल जाता हूं इस
चक्कर के अंदर अपना मेरे को पसंद नहीं आया
मैं लिखा गया था
तो कमेंट्स रहते हैं जिम क्या राहत है की
अपन वो कंपाइलर अपना जो ये इंटरप्रेटर
राहत है वो अपना रीड नहीं करता है उसको
इग्नोर कर देता है ये छोटा भाई कुछ नहीं
मजाक किया होगा तो वो क्या राहत है की
उसमें अपन लिख देते हैं की अपन ये कोड
क्या डिफाइन कर रहा है कुछ भी अपन चाहे या
फिर कोई कोड हटाने का है लाइन हटाने का है
बट वहां से रिमूव नहीं करना कमेंट करना है
पर फ्यूचर उसे तो उसके लिए अपन क्या उसे
करते हैं अपन उसके लिए हैशटैग का उसे करते
हैं मालूम है
डायरेक्टली यहां पर ऐसे लिख देता हूं
ठीक है
अब कमेंट यह नहीं की मतलब अपना इस यह
एक ही रहने का कमेंट राहत है मल्टीपल
लाइंस को अगर अपन को जैसे मैंने ऐसे तो
कुछ भी यहां पे लिख दिया
है हां भाई इसका ये मतलब है
ना
थोड़ा वेट करना गैस
हो सकता है
कोई मतलब बोलिए
अगर मैं यहां पर लिखना हूं
इस लाइन स्टेटस
कम आएगा
कौन-कौन से अप को ऑपरेटर वगैरा होते हैं
अपना
अब मां लो की अपन को यहां पर 2 + 3
करेंगे
मैंने भाई प्रिंसिपल
ए रहा था
मोहम्मद अजीज भाई बात ऐसी है की छोरी छोरी
इस चीज को करके देखो और करने के बाद में
खून में मां में लॉजिक बना ऐसा की ये चीज
क्यों हुआ क्या करण है कैसे होने के तो
ज्यादा समझ में आएगा छोरी
आगे कम आगे कम से प्रैक्टिकल आने वाला है
अपने
क्या प्रैक्टिकल आप में कितना प्रैक्टिकल
कितना साउंड कर का रहे हो आप किसी को भी
जाकर बता डॉग नहीं डेट वन क जो दिखने वाला
है वह अपने सामने जो अपने प्रैक्टिकल करके
दिखाए
दोनों के मिल जाते हैं ऐसा वो भी मैं बता
सकता था मैं स्टार्टिंग में इंटरव्यू लिखा
था उसके बाद मैंने हटा दिया की मेरे को
मेरे को देखते की ये कितना तुम लोग को पता
है इसके बड़े में कितना ऐसे समझ में ए रहा
है तो इसलिए
सो मोबाइल कोई दिक्कत की बात नहीं है हो
जाएगा
स्प्रिंग को कर दूंगा अपने डीजल में
कन्वर्ट
[संगीत]
चीजों को लेकर अब इसके अंदर अपन कंपैरिजन
भी कर सकते हैं की भाई अब से बड़ा है क्या
अब मैं चाहूं की ए प्लस बी के साथ में मैं
एक और सी भी दे देता हूं और यहां पर मैंने
इसको ऐसा कर दिया की यहां पर
डेक्सोनिक्स किया है
वह भी कम करेगा अपना अब मैं चाहूं किसी के
ना माइंस वन करके यहां पर
इस कंटेनर
ओके
तो यह साड़ी तरीके से
एड कर सकते हैं
उनको कैसे अपन करें बाकी जो लिस्ट वगैरा
कैसे दाल सकते हैं
यह अपना एक बेसिक सा कोडिंग था और कोडिंग
वाले पार्ट के साथ-साथ अपना ये भी हो गया
अपना वैरियेबल्स टाइप्स
कर है तो एक बार मुझे बता दो यहां पर
आज थोड़ा बेसिक
ग रहा रहेगा
नो डाउट प्लीज भाई आपको तो आता है दौड़
कहां से आएंगे
तो इंग्लिश
आई है
यह बाकी अपना लैंग्वेज सिस्टम
तो इसलिए भाई इंग्लिश में तो भी चलेगा
तो वह बोली ने वाली रिटर्न करेगा
क्या भाई
क्लियर हो गया क्या
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में पाइथन कैसे कम आएगी
अगर कोई चीज अगर आपको बार-बार करनी पद रही
है या फिर मां लो पेन टेस्टिंग करनी है
उनको मां लो की कुछ भी टेस्टिंग वाला
पार्ट भी करना हो या फिर एक चीज आपको
रिक्वेस्ट वगैरा करनी है तो उन सबके लिए
पाइथन कम आता है पाइथन का रिक्वेस्ट राहत
है जिसके बड़े में बात कर सकते हैं अपने
प्रोजेक्ट के अंदर भी कम आएगा
तो वहां पर भी इसका उसे बहुत ज्यादा होता
है
और खुद के टूल्स वगैरा
बनाने जाएंगे
उतना ही कम आता है
सो दूसरे बनाने क्या अगर आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कम्युनिटी से हो तो आप मतलब
कोई भी टोल आप देख लेना अधिकतर टूल 50%
टूल्स तो आपको पाइथन में दिखे ही जाएंगे
जो अच्छे अच्छे बड़े-बड़े टोल और में पान
में खुद पैसे में लिखा हुआ है और में आपका
एक मोडल भी है जो अपना पाइथन के अंदर उसका
इंस्टॉल करोगे तो पैसे के अंदर
क्या रहेगा की सबको यह इंसुलेशन आज करके
स्क्रीनशॉट खींच के अपना यहां पर बताने का
है
सिक्योरिटी सर्च करोगे
टैक्स उनको यहां पर आकर बताने के हैं जैसे
अभी इंस्टॉलेशन तुम बुक करके बताना है की
आपने सॉल्यूशन हो गया है तो इस सॉल्यूशन
का स्क्रीनशॉट खींच के यहां पे डालने का
है और ये यूजर और फुट का लेकर और मतलब
उसके पूरा कोड बना के यहां पे दाल देना है
की यूजर का भूत कैसे लेकर आप शो कर रहे
हैं आज के लिए बस इतना ही बताने का
इंसुलेशन का स्क्रीनशॉट और यूजर से इनपुट
लेकर आपको दिखाने का है या आपने ये इनपुट
ले लिया है तो ये लिंकडइन पर ही आपको
बताने का है यहां पर यहां पर पोस्ट के
अंदर यहां पे नीचे कमेंट कर देना
पाइथन का पोस्ट आएगा पाइथन के पोस्ट पर भी
कमेंट कर देना और वहां पर मैं वहां से देख
लेंगे जो भी वहां पर रिप्लाई होगा वही
रिप्लाई कर दिया जाएगा तो यही आज के लिए
थैंक यू